I'm joined today by attorney Scott
Oswald who represents employees has
litigated nearly 50 trials to verdict
and we're going to be talking today
about some different elements related to
the recent string of sexual harassment
and sexual assault allegations that
we've seen so first speaking very
generally Scott and it's really great to
have you when we talk very generally
about the term sexual harassment or
sexual assault not everything that falls
under that umbrella is necessarily
criminal is that right yeah that's
exactly right I mean certainly any kind
of offensive touching most certainly
would be in most jurisdictions but you
know the kinds of things that we see in
the workplace all the time things like
the worst behavior jokes that are
sexually tinged that can be a violation
of our our employment laws and certainly
for employers create real real problems
potentially well went unchecked so when
we talk about what is potentially
criminal and what is not and how
employees who at least in the workplace
are being targeted or victims of this
type of behavior or actions what's
important for employees to know when
potentially am I supposed to be talking
to the police and when are these sort of
more human resource matters that that
need to be dealt with yeah I think if we
want to draw a bright line and it's not
always easy to do so I think we
certainly can start with touching any
time there is physical touching that is
offensive and certainly if it is with
some kind of sexual proposition that is
out of bounds and in most cases if it's
if it is unwanted that may be something
that would require outside examination
including you know potentially a
criminal charge I think we can use our
common sense to anything where there is
a sexual assault as an example that
certainly would would war
potential criminal involvement and law
enforcement involvement other kinds of
things in the workplace it's always a
good idea to notify the company because
a company has an obligation David to
actually create a safe and healthful
workplace and if they don't do so and
that company can be liable so it's
always a good thing to notify the
company right away if you think that you
know something has happened in the
workplace that you think just you know
isn't quite right can you talk a little
bit about how power dynamics influences
how a lot of these incidents are dealt
with by employers because we can all
imagine a situation where if if there is
a c-level executive for example or
someone that that is sort of above human
resources in the organizational chart
who is maybe engaging in some of this
behavior we can all imagine how going to
Human Resources is not necessarily going
to be an experience where Human
Resources will be an unbiased arbiter of
what took place if they also are subject
to that those exact same power dynamics
so can you address how that might be
managed in some way well first off to
begin with that's a bad system I mean
anytime Human Resources is reporting in
to a person or persons that they then
have to investigate I mean that that's
just a recipe for for impotence and you
know in in with societies like the site
Human Resource Management other employer
organizations they have systems that
they recommend that employers Institute
where you have you can report for
instance outside Human Resources or
maybe anonymously to the board directly
when you you feel as if Human Resources
is influenced inappropriately by you
know someone above them that might be
involved in in the harassment but I
think a generally that the first place
to go is Human Resources and the reason
I say that David is that that the law
says
our Supreme Court has said that when an
employee notifies his or her human
resources department and does so
promptly and does so in a specific way
the law then will protect them the key
though is is to make sure people in the
company are aware of what's going on and
doing so as soon as you possibly can we
know from experience that there is a
degree of stigma in society about coming
forward and saying I was a victim of X Y
or Z can you talk a little bit about
from a legal standpoint how statutes of
limitations can actually create an issue
when there is a delay in coming forward
but also about ways in which it doesn't
matter and wit in which claims are just
as valid later than they would be
immediately after an alleged incident
you know III think it's really important
because there is this stigma I think out
there the sense that you know if I'm
coming forward I necessarily am a victim
I'm the one who should be blamed and I
think it should be just the opposite you
know that the reality is that in the
employment space in particular we we all
ought to be on equal footing and
certainly we all ought to expect from
our employers that employer is going to
create that safe space for us I mean
that's the law requires that and so
there there is nothing wrong about
coming forward and I think it's an
employer's obligation to make that very
clear to its employees so how does an
employer do that I think the best way is
really in training you know the
employers that routinely train their
employees and I'm not talking about just
some sort of online module where you go
and you know you check some boxes but
real training where you bring employees
in and you explain to them the
importance of coming forward and
notifying the company so the company can
do something about that actors and
create that that safe space and to make
it very clear to employees that
that the company will take any complaint
seriously we'll move quickly to
investigate and we'll take prompt
corrective action will potentially
remove that employee that's been a
sexual harasser as an example from the
from the workspace so really is the
company's obligation to remove that
stigma to to make employees feel as if
if they come forward they're going to be
lauded and they're gonna be listened to
and and not retaliated against so that
that certainly tells us about how the
employer can manage circumstances when
they're sort of have been allegations or
to create an environment where people
are comfortable coming forward and
saying hey here's what happened I got a
call from one of our viewers last week
saying something along the lines of hey
how can employers prevent sexual
harassment in the first place and I
think that that's difficult I mean my
reaction was if by the time you're an
adult and you get hired somewhere you
don't yet know that it's not okay to do
these things I don't know how much an
employer can really do can you talk
about that a little bit yeah so the
first thing is is to make sure that the
people you let in the door know those
things you know background checks
careful review of references you know
what we're seeing I think in each one of
these instances in in the media is that
these are not one-off situations these
are men that seem to do this over and
over and over again and so they develop
a reputation and if an employer does its
job in vetting employees at the outset
especially senior people that they're
bringing in to make sure that they are
not individuals who have a you know a
track record for doing these types of
things I think that's critical how does
it do that though because presumably I
mean I'm just thinking through like okay
you check references very carefully you
can't necessarily go and talk to people
that were managed by your applicant
right because more than likely their
references are either colleagues or
people even senior to them or in c-level
cases maybe even boards of directors
how can you say how can you get access
to I guess the people who might actually
know or be willing to talk about that
prior track record so I think the first
place is those previous employers and
what we're seeing is employers know a
lot more about some of these people then
maybe they let on and at the outset so
getting releases from prospective
employees and saying look we are going
to contact your former employers and
we're going to ask lots of questions
that kind of careful review of the
person's background at least puts us in
a position that if it's known to a
previous employer that you're going to
uncover it and you know even in
situations where a former employer is
reluctant maybe to go into all the
details they're going to send you
signals for instance you might ask you
know would you hire this person again
would you rehire mr. x4 in a position of
trust and you don't get the right answer
that's someone that you you need to you
need to stay away from as an example so
I think it all begins first in a
thorough vetting of people that you're
bringing into your organization into
your safe space the second I think
component of this is that you know
you're right David I mean clearly some
people have not been did they they
haven't had proper upbringing in terms
of what is is okay and what is not and
so they you know some people need to be
taught I mean just like you bring people
in and you teach them about your IT
systems you teach them about your
culture in the company you teach them
what is what is right and what is wrong
and in particular what is wrong in the
workplace when when dealing with your
your colleagues what kinds of
interactions you can and what kind of
interactions you you you shouldn't have
making sure that you're not putting your
employees in a position where they you
know they're they're vulnerable you know
when you are sending your employees
off-site as an example let's say for
travel I mean having very clear
guidelines of
what people should and should not do
when they're on travel for instance I
mean we're seeing in the news as an
example some people coming forward and
saying look this is what's what happened
to me when I was on travel with this
person if there had been clear rules
guidelines the do's and don'ts when
you're away from the office maybe those
things wouldn't have happened in the
first instance so I think that the onus
really is on the employer to set those
guidelines to make sure that they're not
having company events that are going
late into the night where there is
alcohol being served as an example these
kinds of things I mean you take a few of
these steps to ensure that you know your
people are are in continue to be in safe
spaces then the chances that that you're
going to have people who will slip is is
much reduced we've been speaking with
attorney Scott Oswald he is an attorney
who represents employees he's also
managing principal of the Employment Law
Group a very important and timely topic
Scott thanks so much for talking to us
about it hey David you're welcome it is
my pleasure